we're talking about wokism to you is
that a cult
it is
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster
i'm constantine kissing and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
and the fascinating guest we have for
you today he's an ex-scientologist
author and youtuber chris shelton
welcome to trigonometry
thank you very much i'm very happy to be
here and we are very happy to have you
listen let's get straight into
i should mention at the beginning that
we'll talk about cults
including some of the ones we discussed
quite regularly on the show uh
later on in the interview but let's
start with your story you got involved
in scientology you spent 27 years in one
shape or form in that
whole situation tell everybody from the
very beginning to the very end how did
that all happen
excellent i was four years old when my
parents got involved
and yeah my uncle wrangled my dad in my
dad wrangled my mom
in and they did communications classes
and thought it was the
bee's knees and they started becoming
scientologists
and um and they were divorced
and they got back together so my entire
childhood i credited to scientology
to having a family that was the big
selling point for me as a kid
and um and then i was sort of around it
raised with the principles of it just
like any other religious household
it was pretty you know pretty hardcore
indoctrination
um all of my parents friends
friends fan you know all of that
scientologists
so very kind of bubble worldly sort of
growing up
even though i did go to public school i
did have that experience
and then after high school or actually
while i was still
in high school is when i started doing
my own
class work and really getting involved
so that when
i finished high school they recruited me
to join staff
and start working for the church and
they totally changed my career path i
was going to go be a writer
and you know i was kind of aspiring to
be a a new stephen king or something
and this is 1987 and this background
this is back always and
i um was instead convinced
that my talents would better be utilized
saving the world
and i went all in they really got me and
uh
and so i ended up working for the church
and i worked in santa barbara at the
local church of scientology there
for eight years it was a very
um hard existence because i had a
full-time job at the church which was
considered
volunteer work and then i had to have
another full-time job to support myself
so all i was doing was working
it was like 80 90 hour work week and so
really the only time i had off was
weekend nights to do my laundry and
and stuff like that that was my
existence for about eight years i was
really dedicated really hardcore
and i there's a lot of abuse of nonsense
that happened during those eight years
while i was in santa barbara
but that pales in comparison to what
happened when i was 25 and i decided
well
this santa barbara thing is fun and nice
and all that was said with scientology
and we're trying to make a difference in
the world with this
but we're not we're small we're tiny
there's nothing really happening here
i want to make a difference i got to
save the world i was really on that
bandwagon
so i stepped up to what is called
the sea organization uh sca
is in the ocean it's a paramilitary
naval
outfit that uh hubbard created
all by himself invented it in 1967 and
the most
hardcore what i really the most
fanatical scientologists
are the ones who go into or get
recruited for the sea organization
and that's a 24 7 all you're
doing is scientology kind of a setup
you don't have any other life so you go
and you live on a sea org base which is
set up like a military base with dorms
and
a galley and they feed you and they
uniform you and uniforms and
and it's yes sir no sir and ranks and
ratings and all of it it's all there
and there's about four you know four to
five thousand i think when i was in it's
about five thousand i think now it's
descended down to about 3 500 people
internationally who are the sea org
so it's a small group and we had it in
our minds that we were saving the world
and it was a very very physically and
emotionally
it ordeal it was an ordeal it was it was
quite a thing and that was
that was another 17 years that i did
that
wow yeah i was i was really dedicated
and i
and i and i really i keep saying that
because i want to get across to people
that
that the power of of a purpose of a
belief of an idea
is there isn't anything i i believe
there is nothing in this world more
powerful than
what we can do with our ideas and um
and i kind of lived that for for 25
years working for the church
i had so many bad experiences i cannot
even begin to detail them all here but
for example
three years of that 17 years was spent
on a re-education prison type program
called the rehabilitation project force
it's an internal
maoist re-education camp that exists
within the sea org within the world of
scientology it's it's
it's not a well-known thing and it took
me three years to go through this
quote unquote rehabilitation program
which really meant that i was spending
most of my day
anywhere from 10 to you know 13 14 hours
a day
on hard physical labor
you know retarding roofs in the hot
summer sun setting up
stages and events building furniture
hardcore stuff
and uh that wasn't that wasn't too much
fun that was the first time i ever broke
a bone
in my body um doing some work there and
getting pushed around and there was a
guy who lost an
eye there were people who had very very
bad physical things happen to them as a
result of that program and
and i and i'm not even getting into
right now the
depths of the psychological manipulation
that occurs i called it a maoist
re-education camp because that's
actually the closest thing i can think
of
to describe what this what this program
was like
and that was just one part of the whole
experience the entire scientology
experience is one of
mental and you know psychological and
emotional manipulation
and uh i was physically assaulted
there's physical
violence as well so um it was not a fun
time but it was you know it was it was
a life of dedication and discipline and
it was and i thought in my mind i was
comparing it to the kind of dedication
that one would see in monks or
or nuns in a monastery type of situation
like it's that
you know we're dedicated we are hardcore
we mean it we're in it to win it
and there was a lot of esprit de corps
there was a lot of like yeah we're
riling each other up all the time right
but at the same time here's the problem
with this
is one we weren't saving the world and
two
it's a snitch culture it's a 1984 kind
of culture quite literally so you're
always reporting on each other
and it's a very domineering
authoritarian
setup and your rights your human rights
your civil rights
they don't matter in an environment like
that
the mission is the only thing that
matters the you know what we're doing
and of course after all these years of
abuse and nonsense
um i started waking up it was a
slow process because it had been
something had been part of my entire
life i've been part of this since i was
four years old
l ron hubbard was presented to me by my
parents
who i loved and respected as
a genius philosopher scientist
brilliant writer that was l ron
hubbard's positioning to me growing up
so i thought this guy was great and i
thought everything he said was true
and he says some pretty ridiculous stuff
to say the least he talks about you know
uh taking spiritual journeys to venus
and mars
and you know he talks about
intergalactic space civilizations and
aliens and a lot of a lot of interesting
crazy stuff
but i thought it was all true because i
was raised to literally believe it was
true
so it took a long time and a lot of
abuse had to be rained down on me before
i started going you know i don't think
this is what it says it is
and that rpf program i mentioned was a
big part of waking up because you go
through three years of intense physical
abuse hard physical labor
psychological manipulation and some
pretty intense gaslighting
and it changes you you know you start
thinking about things in a different way
so finally in 2012
i got out of the sea organization i had
come to the point of realizing that then
that the organization of scientology
this guy david miscavige who heads the
church and what they were doing
was more about money than it was about
actually helping people
surprise right
i mean i should say i always neglect to
say this from the get-go
it's a money-making scam that's what
scientology
is okay there's no legitimacy to it
whatsoever
i don't even think of it as a legitimate
religion and
and there are arguments to be made on
both sides of that but that's where
that's where i come from
so i finally started waking up it took
years for me to accept to come to the
realization that
maybe the organization was off
i still thought the subject was good and
i still thought o ron hubbard knew what
he was talking about
i just thought miscavige was kind of
running it off a cliff
so i got out of the sea org but i still
wanted to do scientology and i was still
dedicated
as a scientologist it would be
equivalent to maybe leaving a parish or
a church or something because you're
like you don't like the deacon or the
or the bishop or the minister but you
still think you know god's real right
so i get out
and here's another thing that's going on
in this group
many things are going on but one of the
one of the key things is
information control i didn't have
internet access
hardly at all and certainly never saw
south park
never knew about tom cruise's craziness
with oprah
never knew about so many things i mean
there were just
tons and tons of lies just
just rivers of lies and what happened is
after i got out
i was able to get on the internet for
real like really deep dive
i had had some exposure to a few
negative things while i was
working in scientology because you know
information kind of passes around
but this is a group where everybody
who's in it
really does believe in it we're all true
believers so we weren't
looking for negative information we
weren't trying to be critical
and chris you said that you believe in
it right
i'm gonna be honest every time i read
about scientology i don't
really understand it what do you believe
in oh well
okay um well let me let me
answer that in just a moment let me just
quickly wrap this up by saying
once i got on the internet three months
later
it was all over right all over i was out
mentally out but i was still physically
scientologist i still had all these
scientology friends
i had just left working for the sea org
but i was still trying to make my way in
this world
and that's when i started speaking up
so anonymously at first i was posting on
forums and message boards and chat
boards and stuff
not under my own name and then by the
end of 2013
which was the year that this all went
down kind of the best and worst year of
my life
um best because i discovered the truth
worst because
i lost everybody scientology shuns they
it's called disconnection and if you
step out of line if you step out of the
rules if you if you question
anything that's going on you're shunned
sounds like the comedy industry in this
country mate exactly
so it's not it's it's sort of cancel
culture on steroids right yeah
not only will they cancel you they will
continue to go after you if you keep
talking if you keep speaking up so um
so i got out and so by the end of 2013
basically a year
after i had left i was no longer a
scientologist i was actually speaking
out against it
and um i set up a blog and in 2014 i
came out under my own name
and started speaking out loud and proud
because the church
had figured out that i was speaking out
and they disconnected me
and they declared me what's called a
suppressive person
or an sp i'm an sp i'm a bad guy
and that's the definition there in
scientology the that's the equivalent of
being an
anti-social psychotic personality
clearly you know so yeah
uh so that's the story right there's
tons of details i mean so many things to
get into with that but that's the broad
strokes of it
as and now let me answer your question
scientology
is presents itself as let me put it this
way
scientology presents itself as a
religious philosophy
where the basic core belief is that you
me everybody are spiritual beings
spiritual entities
that are called satans to differentiate
it from soul or spirit or ghost or
something
and um the satan has lived forever
can't die he's gonna live forever that's
you
you're gonna live forever you're always
gonna be around but the quality of your
existence is in question because you've
been around for a long time
living life after life after life you
know you have a body
you grow the body you live the life the
body dies
you as a spirit are then compelled
hubbard says to go get another body go
down to the hospital and pick up a baby
body
that no other satan has glommed onto yet
right
and you grow that body and live that
body as though that's you and that's
your life and you believe as a spirit
because you have been compelled to
through a great deal of force and and uh
pain and stuff
um you have been compelled to believe
that you are a body that's all you
are and and hubbard the analogy would be
probably the easiest way to think about
this
is if you if you think of your body
as like a doll it's like a barbie doll
and kids play with dolls but what if the
kids started thinking they
were the dolls that's the current state
of mankind according to l rob hubbard we
all are running around thinking we're
we're we're this this is all there is to
life
so there's a lot of hope there's a lot
of like wow there's a big wide
there's all these possibilities and
similar to the
to the confidential upper levels of the
mormon
lds church there's a concept at the
higher levels of scientology that you
actually achieve a state of godhood
and that through the practices of
scientology
they will lead you down this path that
will take you to a place of spiritual
immortality
and understanding and spiritual ability
so you know hubbard talks in his
lectures about
you know superpowers like telekinesis
and telepathy and
you know clairvoyance and stuff like
that as things all of us potentially
can do sign me up mate that sounds great
well not not only does it sound great
but actually it's not entirely out of
whack with quite a lot of different
spiritual movements religious
and cultural movements throughout
history so so far
i'm not i mean i'm not saying it it's
necessarily appealing to me but
it's not out of whack with quite a lot
of
uh other uh movements let's say
exactly you're nailing it and and that's
the surface that's the veneer that's the
sales job
right here's here's what it is it's this
great thing and we're going to improve
you
we're going to give you a tool kit for
life we're going to give you all these
practical tools you can use to
handle your finances communicate with
your kids
get along better with your boss or your
spouse
you know real practical living stuff and
do they do
do they give you that do they give you
tools to do that does that stuff work
well some of it does some of the time
right and that's the lower level common
sense
stuff right like for example uh a
scientology principle
is when in doubt communicate
hmm well that's a principle that served
me pretty well
if i'm having a problem with somebody i
communicate to them about it
i don't just sit on it and i don't just
make assumptions
and you know a lot of people have
problems with that they have a problem
with
with stepping up and and and having what
could potentially be a confrontational
conversation either with friends or or
somebody they're having a problem with
scientology has some practical exercises
you can do
in one of their lower level
communications classes
that can teach you to kind of be a
little bit more bold and a little bit
more willing to step
up it doesn't teach you to yell and
scream at people as a confrontational
measure
it teaches you how to look somebody in
the eye and
you know say something that somebody
else can hear
this is really toastmasters level stuff
this is not
you know any speaking group is going to
teach you how to do this stuff
it's not scientology is wonderful stuff
it's that
this is common sense but it's packaged
in such a way and elrond hubbard talks
about it in such a way as to make it
sound like it's this wonderful unique
incredible
stuff that he is the only one
who could through his genius come up
with all of it
right it's like he's he he was a writer
and he wasn't
necessarily a bad one sometimes he was
he was very good at manipulating
people and chris the unique thing for me
about scientology
isn't really what you've actually said
it's the way that it
harnesses celebrity as a marketing tool
in order to get people to enroll that to
me i wouldn't want to use the word
genius but in a way it is genius because
i don't see any other religion that has
done that that's exactly right and it
was a dedicated
strategy on the part of l ron hubbard as
early as 1955
to wrangle in celebrities and use them
as a front as a
as a as a pr front to get more people in
and that strategy worked in spades for
scientology
the truth of the matter is that
scientology probably wouldn't exist
right now if it wasn't for two people
john travolta and tom cruise
and uh they have in turns
been the voice and public face of
scientology and have been
very active in talking about the
benefits of it
for decades john travolta is a true
believer he's also a real nice guy
i met him he is he's genuinely a nice
guy but he's completely deluded
and he's all in just like i used to be
tom cruise on the other hand
is a bit of a different kettle of fish i
have many more critical things to say
about him
right should we go down there are we
going to get he's got very powerful
lawyers and a lot of money maybe
maybe let's take it easy on that one
but so so you leave you become this
you essentially excommunicated for for
the crime of speaking out
uh and i imagine there's a sort of
rewiring in your brain that happens
that's right that's right that's right
it's called the recovery process
and recovering from scientology or
or a high control group as we like to
call them i mean you could use the term
you know lots of terms destructive cult
high control group authoritarian group
um recovering from these groups is no
joke it usually takes professional
intervention and and that's not saying
that there's something wrong with you
that you're so
screwed up that that's what you need
it's
actually the fact that pretty much you
know a lot more people than his
generally realized could use smell
but this is not a process you want to do
by yourself is my point
i've been learning and and talking about
and advocating for and
and trying to educate on the subject of
the recovery process
and my channel my work has been
an effort to try to share my own
experience my own
work on this and help other people along
with the process
and then at the same time try to educate
the world at large
so that we have less people who need to
do this kind of process
because it's there are there are way too
many of these groups out there
far more than just scientology and you
the thing that i find interesting is the
celebrity element
oh are the celebrities not aware of
what's going on
no they're not they are kept in
insulated isolated worlds that are
actually even more
insular than the scientology bubble
world
the celebrity world is something i've
learned a lot about after getting out of
scientology and of course
i'm friends with a couple celebrities
and and you know like leah who's an ex
scientologist yourself and
and so you learn some things and and one
of the things that i've learned is that
you know when you become a public figure
uh and i'm sure you guys are aware of
this right
it limits your options in some in some
cases you can't go out all the time in
some situations or
you know especially the big celebrities
right you can't just go down to the pub
you can't just go hang out right you're
gonna get mobbed
so uh you learn that you have to
rely on certain people they're the
key people become very important in your
life to manage your affairs help
organize
things set up logistics etc and when
those
people are scientology celebrities
scientologists then they're going to
trust other scientologists
and so they surround themselves with
scientologists and the church of
scientology goes out of its way
to make this happen and facilitate it
they even have
their own separate sub organization
within the church called celebrity
center
and it's it's spelled british spelling
by the way c-e-n-t-r-e
and it is um because it was
created by an australian and the
celebrity center network
is a group of or scientology churches or
organizations that are specifically
dedicated
only to celebrities in their entourages
it's that
important and the main one is in los
angeles
that's where the main where the big
celebs go and
uh they have an office called the office
of the president
and the president's office of the
celebrity center is the control
network for all the scientology
celebrities
they brief them they drill and practice
with them about how to talk about
scientology
and media and how not to talk about
scientology how to avoid certain
questions
this is why tom cruise gets a pass all
the time because he refuses
to answer any questions on the subject
he just won't be confronted on it
and all of his handlers and people who
are around him are all scientologists
so they're not gonna let any of the
negativity about scientology go anywhere
near that celebrity if they can help it
and is it advantageous in for instance
if you want a career
in in the media or acting to
be a scientologist is it will they pull
strings in order to help you progress
or does it not work like that it doesn't
work like that anymore
for a period of time back in the 80s and
90s
they had some pull in hollywood with the
exposure that happened in the 2000s and
the whole meltdown that happened in the
mid-2000s
everything changed and the then sort of
the gloves came off with the media
and um scientology was defanged in many
ways
i'm not in at all implying that they are
not a dangerous organization still
because they are
and they are they're incredibly abusive
but publicly the amount of power they
have in hollywood
has just plummeted because of the
exposure
of all of the abuses chris i want to
open it up to
uh beyond just scientology and i think
the question that interests me is
what's the difference between a cult
which is
i think what you would say scientology
is and the religion
great question um and to be even more
specific
a destructive cult um because if you
open up a dictionary and you look up the
word cult
any religion almost any group that has a
dedicated
you know part to it could be considered
a cult
but a destructive cult is the term we
use because it it makes it clear that
this is an abusive organization that's
going to hurt you more than it's going
to help you
and when it comes to that
differentiation what we're talking about
are actions what they do and i stress
this over and over again
a cult is not a group with a weird
belief set
because there is no group anywhere that
somebody couldn't think is weird
right every group is weird it's
what do they do with those beliefs
because that's what you can watch and
that's what you can prove and that's
what you can actually regulate
and so what we are looking at with
destructive cults is groups that
use a belief set or an ideology
to radicalize
to you know promote a non-constructive
agenda you could say whether it's
financially rapacious
and it's bankrupting its members left
right and center which is
what scientology does in many of these
other groups
whether it's physically violent whether
it's radicalizing people in the
direction of
you know even terrorist activities stuff
like that i mean we see
heaven's gate years ago which was a
suicide
ufo cult all its members killed
themselves
that's pretty destructive right that's a
belief set
in forming action and so this is where
my demarcation line is this is the
important part is
it's not what they believe it's what
they do with those beliefs
destructive cults isolate manipulate and
control
what's called coercive control but how
is that
different and i'm just genuinely trying
to understand the difference so
there are religions which elements of
which encourage people to commit violent
acts
right mainstream religions there are
religions which encourage
individuals not to get married or have a
family which is
one of the basic building blocks of the
human condition you might argue
there are religions that encourage
people to
donate large sums of money or even tithe
a portion of their earnings to a church
they're religions that do all sorts of
things
that essentially require people to live
a
in a way that you might argue is
completely against their
sort of material interests or practical
interests right
so what's the difference between
elements of islam elements of judaism
elements of christianity elements of
hinduism elements of buddhism and
what you're talking about is there a
difference how can you tell
it's again it's really a matter of what
do they do with those beliefs beliefs
inform
action um for example okay here are some
characteristics that we can talk about
us versus them thinking right black and
white thinking right our way or the
highway
a destructive cult is is a group that
has a belief set like any other group
but there's there's this scale of of of
extremism you could say
and you cross a line when it's no longer
acceptable that you
think your own thoughts that you have
independent thinking that you be
critical at all of this group or or
what's going on
in it that you might want to step away
from it for a little while you know one
thing that that is
used as a judgment factor sometimes is
what happens sometimes the only way you
can tell a group is a cult is what
happens when you try to leave
right what do they do and these groups
tend to
be rather extreme about keeping you they
try to
go way out of their way to control your
life and control your thinking and
control
your behavior um and they're overriding
your own
your own determinism right and that's
where there's this point where
it's gone too far where you are
being controlled i guess i could say you
know where there's coercion being used
against you if it's it you know
every group has rules
but you go in knowing what those rules
are and agreeing to it and if you do
that
it's a little hard for me to make
judgments about it like you know if you
want to go be a catholic
monk and go live in a monastery and live
the ascetic
life i can't tell you that's wrong
that's your choice to make with your
life
but
if i tell you i'm going to give you the
dream job of your life and you're going
to save the world and it's going to be
wonderful you're going to get paid a lot
you're going to meet wonderful people
you're going to get travel the world and
it's going to be awesome
and then i stick you in a monk's gossip
and stick you in a monastery on the top
of a mountain and go have at it
i've i have presented something very
different from the reality of that
picture right and i've told you you know
i sold you on this whole bill of goods
i'm being a little exaggerated to make
the point but
you know these the the point is
are you being abused in the group is
there is there physical
emotional psychological abuse levied
against you
and is there is there informed consent
do you know what you're getting into
or do you not know what you're getting
into do they do stuff to you that you
never agreed to in the first place
and chris what techniques would they use
in order to groom people
so that they then could become
scientology members and followers
well it's really interesting because
what they try to do is uh and this is
pretty uniform from group to group
uh when we're especially when we're
talking about these religious or
self-help groups
is um they try to find some weakness
something inside you
you know some problem you're having some
emotional difficulty you're having
trauma stress you know change in your
life
uh recent loss uh something like that
and uh convince you that they can solve
that problem
and so then you go in and and maybe you
get a little bit of relief a little bit
of help somebody actually listens to you
for once
that's a very powerful force by the way
just having somebody listen to you
um then you start thinking this stuff
works
you slowly get more and more and more
involved in it and
before you know it you're all in and um
in terms of techniques man they're all
over the place there's
i mean it's it's propaganda technique to
get you
in and then it's a series of
gas fighting
i mean eventually there's enough abuse
that it's that it becomes a situation of
traumatic bonding or learned
helplessness in other words they're
abusing you and they're helping you and
they're abusing you and they're helping
you and they're abusing you and they're
helping you
and this back and forth is kind of what
messes with your head psychologically
like okay you go in and you think this
is the greatest group ever and the
leader is wonderful and you go talk to
the leader and he's kind and he's
wonderful and he's beneficent
and he gives you good advice but then
the next day he tells you he doesn't
have any time for you and go away
and then you come back the next day and
he's all nice and smiles again
and it's this kind of pattern right
and it keeps you coming back it's weird
it's a weird thing in our psychology
that it keeps coming back for more
it's really interesting and so um
you see i i keep i'm stuck on the
religion question because
even a lot of the stuff you're
describing like uh
the punishment for apostasy there are
plenty of religions that have pretty
strict uh rules about that that may not
be presented to you right at the
beginning when you're being
indoctrinated certainly
you know i grew up in in the former
soviet union there are a lot of orthodox
christians particularly now
who have very similar ways of behaving
to what you're describing and
islam is the same and other branches of
christianity are the same
so i guess what i'm asking is how do you
know
if someone's watching this how do you
know that you are in the destructive
cult of some kind
right uh okay so in these big broad
religions
you have churches or groups or or in you
know individuals running
little setups those can become very
culty
without the whole without the overall
religion itself
being a destructive cult so so we can
get this kind of cult experience going
on in
any of these groups um you know westboro
baptists for example in the christian
world right christianity in and of
itself isn't necessarily destructive
cult but the westboro baptist sure are
so how do you know well do you get to
think your own thoughts
um i'm on twitter so no mate i don't
do you get to disagree what happens if
you disagree
what happens if you have a different
idea from what the leader's dogma or
ideology is
or from what the official textbooks say
can are you allowed to have that kind of
thinking can you disagree with a very
basic principle
and chris we were mentioning we were
talking about wokism
to you is that a cult it is to me it is
yeah just to be straight up blunt about
it i
i think it is i it's and here's the
and here's the problem with with saying
that that people blow up their their
heads blow up immediately is they think
that means that i disagree with the
values
of wokism right human rights civil
rights equal rights so you know
let's let's give an equality of
opportunity
not an equality of outcome right but in
the quality of opportunity
i think that's an important thing like i
agree with all those things
but this this actually speaks to my
point i can agree with all those things
philosophically
but what do people do with them
well some people go so extreme with them
they're so
into having you know human rights for
everybody that they'll kill you if you
don't agree
they'll strip you of your human rights
and say that's justified because
you know you're standing in my way it's
it becomes this my way or the highway
this extremism this fanaticism about it
this inability to consider that other
points of view
or other ways of of of seeing a thing
could be legitimate could have any
reality or truth connected to it in any
way
right that when you have that refusal
that nope
nope nope you know the whole alternative
facts thing
all of that is very culty thinking
because it's
it's all about confirmation bias it's
all about
motivated reasoning these are terms we
use to describe this kind of thinking
this like
this is the i have the conclusion i
already know what's true
so if you're going to try to tell me
something that's not this
i know before i don't even have to hear
it i don't even have to listen to you
i don't have to grant you any importance
or
or anything like that because nothing
you say
matters because i already know the truth
that's the attitude of a cultist and we
see that in the woke
communities do you think that
in terms of when since we've moved
across into the political realm and the
cultural realm
is that the only cult that you see at
the moment or is there other stuff going
on as well
oh gosh no i see uh cultic activity and
propaganda techniques being leveraged
against people on all
sides of political spectrums every
social issue i mean
it really comes down to for me i sort of
i
sort of have a bit of a sociological
look at it
you know i i bounce between psychology
and sociology all the time because i'm
looking at groups and i'm looking at
individuals
and so i can talk you know i i kind of
think in in with both of these things
and so
and sociologically every group has this
kind of lunatic fringe extreme
band to it these true believers
and and it just kind of organically
develops almost
it's not helped at all though
when you get a leader or a leadership
like a group like the you know like the
the elders that run the jws
who are inciting and promoting and
pushing and propagandizing
for that kind of extreme view
and that's what we see a lot in in
politics these days
a lot of people riling up
trying to create you know trying to be
their own little trumps let's say
you know because and we could use that
as an example um i mean all politicians
are kind of like this but
you know they they try to rile it up and
and we've seen
so much of that now on on both ends
of the political spectrums on these
social issues
that we are that that's very divided
it's a very divided situation
and that's um that's because of the
propaganda that's leveled against people
can you give us an example so we'll talk
about the woke
uh stuff in detail i'm sure uh but
maybe elsewhere because i i certainly
see
that in the work side of things and i i
i mean i guess if you went all the way
to the like the extreme of like q and on
whatever
it does exist on the right but to me
that is a tiny majority fringe where i
think the woke movement seems to be much
more
commonplace and widespread at least
that's my interpretation
so can you give can you give me your
sense of where else it's happening and
some of the you talk about the
propaganda techniques can you give us
some examples
oh absolutely um well cable news
networks
right um i mean we've that's to me one
of the biggest problems
i see in our modern world is is cable
news networks and
becoming propaganda machines rather than
sources of information or news
um we did a show on this couple weeks
ago on my channel where
you know can a news source become a cult
become culty well q anon shows us that
it can
and so if we take that and look at or
analyze
news sources whether it's fox cnbc
msn bc right cnn um
are your big three and they and you kind
of break down
what their schedule and what they're
doing and who's commentating versus
who's actually reporting and what are
they reporting and how are they
reporting
what is what's the factualness of it the
the they're not news stations anymore
they're propaganda platforms and i and i
i you know i think that's a fairly
extreme thing to say but i think it's
i think it's justified just so people
understand
sorry just to finish this point a new
station
is a station that reports to you events
that have happened
a propaganda station right
a propaganda station is a station that
tells you what you should think
about the thing that's happened and by
the way leaves out all the other stuff
that's happened
and only shows you one aspect of things
that it wants you to focus in on
exactly what we have seemed
to have either gone into denial about
or don't even really generally
understand
is that the news has become
it is big business
it's huge business and so it's not just
about delivering
objective information anymore it's about
changing hearts and minds it's about
manipulating
hearts and minds and um and they're very
powerful
these are incredibly powerful platforms
with the reach to you know millions of
people at a shot
so when you see that stations like fox
news
which doesn't even exist in the uk for a
reason
um or msnbc or cnn and you look at the
fact checking percentages
you know you see numbers like you know a
third or something of what fox news is
reporting is just completely false
um i think it's you know 15 10 or
something on cnn and msbc don't quote me
on those numbers but it's you know
there's there's numbers connected with
this
you can you can actually satisfy it and
break it down and analyze it and
when you have the commentators you know
you used to have newspapers with an
editorial page
now most of the damn newspapers the
editorial page with a little bit of news
and that news is as you said it is half
the news it's
it's the information about the event
that they want to present to you
to either confirm your bias or push you
in a direction of whatever agenda is
being
being forwarded and chris what effect is
this having on society then
well clearly right we have a very
divided society because it what it does
is
here's the problem with it is it takes
away agency from the viewership
because the viewers are not getting the
full story they cannot
critically think about the information
that's presented to them because they
don't have all the information or even
most of it they have a lot of opinions
with a little bit of facts that confirm
the opinions
so that divides people
organically you know you just start
assigning it just it's just the
teammanship the tribalism that isn't
that is part of us
you can use information to rile up that
tribalism
that partisanship because what you do
and here's how you do it the specific
way that it's done
the most one of the most powerful ways
that it's done is by othering
by making the people who don't agree
with you that don't
see things the way you see them as
different
as inhuman as monsters as aliens is like
people who are not
you are not good like you are are not
informed are not
smart like you are
right this is this is part of the
propaganda effort is
the people who watch our news station
are informed
you know fair balanced
smart people all those other ignorant
boobs out there
don't know anything and in fact some of
them are
actively working against you and want to
see you
dead when you get
this kind of messaging out of a news
platform
you have a very you know you're capable
of creating an incredibly divided
uh society do you not find it incredibly
worrying chris that
you see you've seen these tactics
being used in organizations as nefarious
as scientology
yet you turn on mainstream media what
should be
objective reporting effects and you're
seeing the same techniques being used
again
that is exactly why i'm sitting here
with you right now
because that's what's kept me sort of
going as a creator as a content creator
you know scientology is a
is a microcosm of a
much bigger problem and that's how i
think about and talk about scientology
now is i've kind of you know i've been
doing this for years
i've created hundreds of videos breaking
down
scientology and there came a point about
four or five years ago where it started
dawning on me
that this is an object lesson this is
not just some experience i'm recovering
from
this is something i should be talking
about to try to help people
understand that we are surrounded by
propaganda and thought reform techniques
because
exactly like you just said you start
studying the subject called thought
reform
some people call it brainwashing or
manipulation or propaganda there's a lot
of ways you can describe it but
how do you change hearts and minds how
do you sway
populations and once you start looking
at that of course you start getting into
pr
and marketing and sales and the tactics
that are used and you start studying
this in some depth
you can go to some pretty dark places
pretty fast because
when you look at things like what
facebook is doing what cambridge
analytica that whole scandal
the the potentiality is a big data
and the power that big data gives to
these platforms that that can use that
data to manipulate
masses of people at a time
you're taking the same techniques elrond
hubbard used to manipulate
one person who walks into their
buildings with and does their
personality test
you take those same techniques and you
apply them to a million people at a shot
you can get some pretty crazy effects
you can get some very destructive
effects on a society
that's what i think my main mission if i
have a mission in life now it's trying
to
trying to point that out to people so
they have a better understanding of it
and can think more critically of it you
know because these are systems we're not
going to change you're not going to
change i'm not going to change it
they're too big there's too much there's
too many people involved in too many
vested interests
well i think that they're starting to
change it for themselves in in
the the the veil has been lifted
somewhat and we're now starting to see
uh you know there's a lot of stuff
coming out i i there's people on the
right who are exposing left-wing
stations as people on the left who
exposing
right-wing stations and i think a lot of
people look at that and they're like
going well
we can tell that they're lying and the
effect is very clear you know the
the most recent example is um cnn's
coverage of covid uh and uh they did
some polling of cnn viewers and they
found that
uh a very large number of them think
that uh essentially your risk of being
hospitalized with covert if you get it
is like 50
when the reality is like one percent
because it's been a real focus
so i guess the question for me would be
how do you as an
individual protect yourself against all
of this stuff do you just switch it off
and don't watch the news at all
and or do you is there some kind of set
of techniques you can use
to be present while you're watching this
stuff and sort of analyze it as it
happens
it's a really good question and it
really it's not it's not an either or
it's actually a little bit of both
um i don't pay attention to
quote unquote news sources when they
have been fact checked routinely
to come up with you know a majority of
or or a good
chunky percentage of just flat out
biased false exaggerated information
right which is why i
rail against all of the the the cable
news
networks because i agree with you
there's there's a slant and an agenda
with all of them
you can though of course gauge for that
and and account for that a little bit
but but not as much as people
think they can't it's actually a little
disturbing how
overly confident people can be in their
ability to discern
truth out of a pile of crap so
because they're not really that good at
it people just kind of think they are
so what you have to do is be more
discerning in the sources of the
information
be more use more than one source though
is probably if there was
one trick to this it's multiple sources
and then of course you can't do any of
this
if you don't know and use critical
thinking skills
there's just no substitute for it if you
don't know what a logical fallacy is if
you don't know what
bias actually is and how to recognize a
biased report from an
unbiased report which is not that hard
to do once you know what to look for
you know it doesn't take forever to
learn how to do this you don't have to
go get a college degree
it's just it does take a little bit of
time and
and it does take a little bit of
education and what do you mean by
critical thinking to somebody because
a lot of people that's a term they just
hear but they don't actually know what
it is what do you mean by that
okay what i might mean by that is not
necessarily taking
in information and just accepting it
it's being critical of it which means
questioning and it's always
questioning it's it's it's an attitude
or a way of approaching data for me more
so than it is even a tool kit
it's it's about okay you have now told
me this piece of information
now i would like to believe that that
information is true because it matches
up with how i would like the world to
look
but let me check that and then you go
and you look it up you google
you talk to somebody you read a book you
can you know there's different ways of
fact checking
but you take a little bit of time
to second third fourth
you know check something over before you
necessarily accept that it's totally
true
or you mark it you bookmark it for you
know later examination
or at least flag it for well this might
be true
but i need to you know i need to do more
work on it
if we could practice that kind of
i don't know having just a little bit
more attention on the way we think about
stuff
it would actually make a tremendous
difference it would be a huge difference
if just that little bit could be
could be added to our thinking process
well i agree with you completely i i
i think the coming and this way may
perhaps the wokeness comes back into it
the problem is as with your experience
in
in the scientology world there are
punishments for doing so
uh and i'll give you you know it's a
controversial example but an important
one nonetheless you know the george
floyd
systemic racism etc or blm let's say
right
uh the narrative doesn't necessarily
match reality so
you if you're an unarmed black person
you're four times more likely to be
killed by lightning than you are by a
police officer
right but that isn't necessarily how
the conversation it plays out in the
media
and then i'm being very gentle about it
right
yeah or blm let's say you could do the
critical thinking which is
what we did when blm became a big thing
we went on the website we read
the things that they say they want to do
defund the police abolish capitalism
uh whatever the reform the nuclear
family requirement whatever as they say
that's right
the moment we raised that as like maybe
we shouldn't do all of this
we got kicked out of our last studio
which is why we're here right
so when you know that no i
well we don't we don't talk about it too
much because we're not really that
bothered by it in the sense that we've
landed on our feet
what i'm do i'm using the example as in
you're asking people to think critically
at a time when a lot of things
are filled with very powerful narratives
where the punishment
for even thinking about it differently
let alone speaking out in public
is so so harsh and so i think a lot of
people
don't think critically about things not
because they're stupid or
incapable of critical thinking but
actually i think a lot of people now the
world that we live in now
don't think critically about things
because they know where that leads
i think that that is i think there's
some truth to that certainly
you know bad consequences uh are a
problem
i think you're actually commenting on
the more culty aspect of our society
like what that divisiveness has sort of
created is that
my way or the highway right the us
versus them kind of mentality
and the fact that that's instilled in us
to the degree that it is at this point
is what is i think the biggest threat
it's not even the content that we're
arguing about is the fact that we are
so us versus them about it you know
um this is it's just it's so frustrating
isn't it
to see it to see it play out this way um
and this is why i rail against these
these platforms because they're the ones
who kind of are creating it
right i mean you get the social dilemma
you got the whole social media problem
so mechanically this is how it's created
unfortunately we're kind of built for
this
yeah right or you know tribalism
tribalism right the the social
hierarchies the the you know thinking
that way
organizing ourselves that way you know
we're kind of our own worst enemy in
some ways on this
um but you know it is what it is
so you mentioned for example the blm
thing well
you know i hear you because i had a show
going
uh as one of the shows i was doing on my
podcast
and i lost somebody because they didn't
really understand what i was saying
about blm
2 you know because i was saying some
similar things
i went i said exactly what you just said
actually kkk i went to their website i
looked at what it said
i talked about that yeah
i said hey there's more here than than
meets the eye
and this whole defund the police thing
is the most ridiculous thing i've ever
heard in my life
so i you know so i took a stand on that
on my channel too
knowing that i was going to lose people
knowing i was going to lose viewers
didn't know i was going to lose a
co-host on one of my favorite shows that
we were doing but i did
you know and that really sucked um so i
hear you on that
you know it's very very divisive out
there um
as far as the critical thinking because
i think we got onto this from the
critical thinking
aspect of this yes
it can be scary to step up yes it can be
scary to ask questions to
to speak out and you have to choose your
battles this is something i've
definitely had to learn over the years
because i used to battle everybody on
everything
you would know that would you might
and you know and it was actually on
reddit of all places that i finally you
know somebody pointed out you know
well you know you got to pick your
battles but whatever you do you and i
suddenly was like oh i guess i am kind
of wasting some time here aren't i
um so there is that aspect to it too
you know um and there's also the other
aspect to this which i've been thinking
about lately which is
you know in the real world uh
when you talk to martial arts masters
when you talk to people who really know
what they're talking about when it comes
to fighting
one for one for one i don't know about
your experience but mine has literally
been a hundred percent
what should i do if if somebody
approaches me if somebody wants to fight
me if i'm confronted the answer 100 of
the time
run don't engage why
why right what's the point
so there's that no no i agree
i agree with that on an individual level
but i think where i would strongly
disagree
is that that is that can be scaled up to
societal
so so you you can say if if a guy who
doesn't like you
who's a nazi comes up to you and starts
a fight
run away if nazi germany invades your
country maybe you need to do something
different right
and to me these large-scale societal
movements are much more in that sort of
category
they are civilizational threats in my
view right
i agree with you and that's actually why
i harp so much
on the social media platforms and the
cable news networks
i look at those as causative agents
in those societal systemic problems
yeah um but they're big you know they're
they're they're too big for any one of
us to do anything about and so
the conversation unfortunately ends up
you know kind of bopping back and forth
between the
the big picture problem well what do i
do about it
you know and and the back and forth of
that
yeah it's because
the thing is with these social media
companies is you're aware
that they're manipulating and it's come
to the point now where even the
executives say
that they don't give their kids a
smartphone
exactly exactly the social dilemma was
very enlightening and uh and opened up a
lot of of uh very interesting
doors for me in terms of understanding
what social media is doing to us
because it's leveraging the same kinds
of control mechanisms that are used in
cults
right attention you know is the
commodity
so they want your attention so they're
going to manipulate your attention
your interest to keep your attention to
keep those eyeballs on the screen
you think you're just viewing your wall
your facebook wall this is just what
your friends have posted
that's not everything your friends have
posted it's what
facebook's algorithms have selected
to show you and then there's of course
the problem with the advertisements
where the advertising and this is really
where things get nefarious
is where targeted advertisements are
used to
actually manipulate thinking uh
political ads is where this comes out
most obviously but then people miss that
it's actually part of every advertising
model
it and and marketing and advertising
is mental manipulation and when you're
using mental manipulation to change
hearts and minds
ideologically so as to create these
partisan camps whether it's on social
issues or straight politics
now you're doing something that nobody
ever asked you to do
and nobody signed up for nobody signed
up for so
on social media platforms to be
manipulated
but that's actually what's happening on
those platforms 24 7.
so to that degree there's a lack of
informed consent you know there's these
things i mentioned earlier in a sort of
stumbling way of
you know if you don't know what you're
getting into
and these people are doing things to you
that you never asked for and never
wanted
that's where things get destructive yeah
that makes a lot of sense
chris listen we could talk for hours and
we i i've certainly really enjoyed it i
imagine we both have
uh but we got to ask you our final
question uh which is
uh what is the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
oh boy such a good question um
i think in all seriousness i don't know
that we're talking about
the importance of critical thinking
education enough
we talk about it at a sort of a surface
veneer level but we don't really dig in
it's sort of like police reform you can
make some surface veneer changes
that might you know sort of sound good
but aren't going to really make any
practical difference
and you can do that with education well
we need to teach critical thinking
yeah but what does that mean how what
you know how exactly what
you know how do we do this and how do we
actually break it down
grade by grade piece by piece
so that it's not just something that is
offered as an elective at college
it's something that needs to be
instilled in people that
not what to think how to think right
from early early early ages but um
but if it's not done right it just
becomes another level of indoctrination
and that's that's the hard part about it
chris it's been absolutely brilliant
thank you so much if people
want to find your work ironically enough
online where is the best place to do
that yes
you can look me up on youtube on my
channel which is just my name chris
shelton
i identify or put myself out there as a
critical thinker critical thinker at
large
and you can find my um my book
scientology adazinu an insider's guide
to what scientology is really all about
on amazon uh where i sell that on
bezos's
authoritarian platform
i have self-published um and it's an
audiobook ebook
and hardcopy books so you can get it
there and that and this book by the way
is not my scientology experience most
scientology books you're gonna find out
there
are a memoir or a breakdown and those
are fine there's no there's nothing
wrong with that i'm not ragging on that
i'm differentiating that that's not what
this is this
is an actual critical analysis of
scientology
so if you really want to know what it's
all about what the beliefs are
who l ron hubbard was why the hell they
still have
tax exemption it's all in the book um
so you're not ragging on those other
books but yours is a lot better
i get them exactly
no i i really want everybody to read all
the books but i just said i just like to
make sure people know it's it's a lot
more than just my story
yeah of course uh chris thank you so
much for coming on and thank you for
watching at home
we will see you very soon with another
brilliant interview or
raw show all of them going out at 7 p.m
uk time
take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below